ya no soy candidato de un solo lado sino
un presidente para que tus
cinco años más en el cargo más alto de
francia para manuel macro quien promete
unir a un país dividido las elecciones
presidenciales de 2022 registraron altas
tasas de abstención como en saint forms
un pueblo cerca de la ciudad oriental de
lyon con una población de 18.000
habitantes aquí casi la mitad de los
votantes no emitió su voto en la segunda
vuelta no tenemos ningún interés en la
política la gente se siente hastiada
nada ha cambiado
ya no hemos encontrado una solución a
los problemas cotidianos del francés
todos están preocupados por otros temas
como el desempleo congreso march en
saint john's el candidato de extrema
izquierda jean luc mélenchon estaba muy
por delante de macrón independent la
primera vuelta ahora los abstencionistas
miran hacia las próximas elecciones
legislativas ya de point no quería verme
obligada a votar por la persona menos
mala me abstuve votará en las elecciones
legislativas por las legislativas y creo
que ir a votar
porque porque tenemos más opciones
como muchas ciudades de francia saint
fans también registró altas tasas de
abstención entre los jóvenes este hombre
trabajador de 24 años cuya familia no es
originaria de francia nunca ha votado en
su vida de una que viene a explicarnos
cómo funcionaban las cosas nuestros
mayores no votaron porque recibieron sus
papeles demasiado tarde o por alguna
otra razón y nosotros la nueva
generación no tampoco tenemos la cultura
de ir a las elecciones presidenciales de
este año ponen en evidencia el malestar
político que sienten muchas personas en
el país la segunda ronda mostró la tasa
de abstención más alta de francia desde